let's ask Steve Kerr Steve would you
rather be you or have the career of
Vince Carter and Allen Iverson or Allen
Iverson think serious yeah yeah we were
just wondering that you know career yeah
I think Vince Carter Allen Iverson you
know how hard it was to beat me out
there on the floor trying to swim
upstream every night I would have been
way more fun to beat okay yeah but you
won titles and then you've coached in
won titles oh yeah yeah yeah you're the
coach yeah the whole package you got you
get to be ste so would you rather be you
player and coach or Vince or Allen
Iverson they start saying like it's
something yeah Nash one time would I
rather have had - Wayman Steve can you
can you go find a little better cell
area you're you're cutting out a little
bit maybe stroll outside or something
you know you know put him on hold
we got would you rather have Vince
Carter cell phone or cell phone Steve
Nash always had a bad cell phone but I
think it was Julie five the she well
yeah I think Julie was there PR person
and Julie would always hand him the
phone when he was done with practice or
something it was always spotty as bad as
Kenny Rosenthal's Kenny Rosenthal
notorious bad cell phone oh yeah yeah
let me try Steve are you back yeah yeah
let me see where are you yeah you're a
little spotty no down in San Diego oh
you're okay yeah yeah here was this one
that we suspended and so I've been down
here with the family ever since
well you're in Del Mar aren't you by
yeah you want to be in Del Mar it's Del
Mar's are pretty good do you have a
basketball court there
I do I do I will not be taking part in
the horse when's the last time you shoot
hoops at practice
I shoot don't shoot against Steph just
just to have a little fun petition and I
can barely move anymore though I can't
shoot jumpers anymore I think hurts free
throws but you guys do something
different than if you touch the rim
that's a Miss isn't it
if I think what we do is yeah if you
know if you if you make it but you touch
the rim it's one but if you swishes -
and if you miss it's - one that's what
we play just play get involved in this
or is it just you and I've only played
looks death and he just whatever he
needs to he just wishes so it's just
incredible it really is I like I rarely
did you know you shooting a free throw
is that stays with you for sure so I
rarely miss but he can swish when he
needs to I can't really do that well but
you still have the best three-point
percentage of all time does that ever do
right does that come up in conversation
with you know once they say all steps
the greatest shooter of all time then
you go but who has a higher three-point
percentage I try not to go down that
path the degree of difficulty on the
shot stand was quite different I think I
don't think I can win an argument we're
talking to Steve Kerr the Golden State
head coach joining us on the program did
you think that Steph had the coronavirus
no no he were worried that had you thick
right when he came back and and then he
missed two games and he had the regular
regular flu so oh we were concerned
about it but he did not yeah I saw the
headline it said in March you know you
said that you were concerned that
Steph's cold was the corona virus but
found out that it was it was just the
flu anybody else with your team
they come down with the coronavirus or
what they thought no no so far nobody on
our team and San Francisco has been hit
too hard I mean I think our mayor was
really on it than with the social
distancing the whole state was really
pretty quick to to get to all these
safety measures and and so most you know
most of the state has been relatively
quiet given the number of people here
have you been able to see the
documentary did they give you an advance
screening of the Bulls documentary the
last dance you know they gave me a link
and I have watched it it's like I'm God
quite sure I maybe I just almost want to
pretend it's gonna be live on Sunday
night I'm crazy craving something live
all wait till Sunday
you had to retell the practice story
where he got punched gosh IIIi don't
think so
wait it's not in the documentary I don't
know yeah I heard it was well I don't
want to ruin the surprise for you I
think you get punched again Steve did I
win the fight this time no you did not
No yeah did you get knocked down with
that punch no no it was like a scrum is
like a rugby scrum you know basketball
brawls are never thank God and yeah well
I think Mike talks about that he's he
wasn't a great teammate but he did
things to motivate players where he
picked on Scotty Burrell I guess he was
really rough on Scotty Braille and
practice yeah he was he was was he rough
on you he was um he was I think I think
he was
he tested me I think he tested everybody
and I think that what you have to do is
you have to stand up to him and and not
necessarily physically which you know I
think basically he talked trash to me
and I talked trash back which wasn't you
know highly advised at the time but it
was I knew I had to stand up for myself
and and I think that looking back and
even at the time I could see what he was
doing you know Michael wanted to make
sure everybody who was out there to deal
with the pressure of a playoff game and
if you couldn't deal with his trash talk
during practice then he didn't think you
were going to stand up to the pressure
during a playoff game and and it made
sense I mean he he brought the level of
practice up to such a high level that
that it made us better as a team and
those are the days when we actually
scrimmaged every day and you know we've
gotten smarter these days we don't we
don't practice as often which saves the
players bodies more but back then we had
competition which may have honed our
edge a little bit more too so now that
was more the case back then and Michael
took advantage of that for sure and it
paid off I think for our team I know as
a player and a coach you can get used to
winning but as a player coach can you
get used to losing I think it's
different as a player and a coach and so
for me this year we have the worst
record the league attacking when the one
play stopped the whole point of our team
and our coaching staff was to try to
maintain the energy and the drive and
the work and keep a positive energy in
the building otherwise you're walking in
there too dreading it every day so we
wanted our young players to feel good
about every day even though we were
losing and still still enjoy it enjoy
the process and enjoy the work
so as a coach you have to keep a much
more positive spirit and positive aura
about you in a season like that and
because it's much more your
responsibility to maintain the tone and
that's what I tried to do this year I
love the name of the podcast with you
and Pete Carroll flying coach sistema so
it's a podcast with Pete Carroll and it
premiered on Monday so you talk about
coaching and mentors and first jobs and
how did this come up that you two are
you guys have you guys been friends for
a long time we've been friends for about
six years and I got connected by a
mutual friend an agent Mike Tannenbaum
was by my coaching agent six years ago
when I decided to coach and he was the
GM of the jet yeah you might remember
him from from hard knocks and and so he
became my agent through my the agency
that's represented me for my whole
career priority sports he took over the
coaching division he was perfect for the
job because he do so many coaches and so
he he took me around and it a bunch of
NFL coaches and he asked me who I wanted
to meet and I told him I wanted to be
Pete Carroll because of Pete's
teams and the way they played and I had
always admired just their style and so I
went to Seattle's camp I'd never met
Pete before and he was so gracious and
and I spent three four days up there and
he was really really generous with his
advice and so we became free and we've
stayed in touch ever since our team has
visited his team we were in Seattle a
couple years ago for an exhibition game
our whole team went to the Seahawks
facility and we won through their
practice for them it was amazing so when
this when this started the suspension of
sports we decided to get together and do
something to try to raise money for
co-ed relief and food banks and this was
the idea we came up with so we're having
fun with it we had one last week we're
doing another one this week if we're
going to try to keep it going
you know for
long as we can while this suspension is
happening do you need any tips I know
you were a professional broadcaster but
I actually could use some tips okay if
you're gonna have people on and you're
gonna interview them yes questions make
them short make them open-ended get them
talking you want them telling stories
that they you're not the star with your
question you'll be the star with their
answer what if I want to be the star oh
okay then listen to how I do it on this
show well and I I will ruin it you know
radio for you for the rest of your life
if you know you start to get into asking
questions and then you're gonna listen
to other people ask questions and go oh
my god that's not open-ended you're
projecting like what are you doing
there's nothing wrong with this question
Steve why how where who can't go wrong
got it I wrote that down yes all right
good luck with that it's called flying
coach is there more information with
this with what you and Pete care or
doing you know you're raising money for
kovat 19 here so yeah so we we're doing
it through the ringer and Spotify okay
bona fide donated $100,000 each to the
Warriors Foundation and the seahawks
foundation so if you live in a Bay Area
or Seattle and you want to make a
donation you can do it through through
those foundations and and everything is
going to go to kovat relief and then as
we get going we're going to sort of
figure figure this out
you know I will see you know we'll see
how much money it makes how many people
are listening if we're going to get some
ad revenue but we're going to sort of
figure it out figure it out on the fine
but we want to we want to do something
really fun and and we entertain people
while they're at home and hopefully
raise the money along the way and you
know so we'll we'll see
would you rather be Michael Jordan or
Phil Jackson I think I think Michael I
think it'd be it's hard not to it would
be hard not to want to be Michael George
just because what he spelled every night
on the floor during his career and
that's what I was talking about earlier
when you asked me would I rather be
Irish Turner Vince Carter
I mean you know to be so dominant to
dominate a game like that must be so
much fun and I I never felt that and
killed you accent never felt that but
there is a joy to coaching and an
incredible experience in that itself so
but Michael Jordan Michael Jordan so I
think I'd rather be Michael Jordan
Steph Curry or Scottie Pippen the
correct answer is Steph Curry he's your
player Scotty Oh get over it it's great
to talk to you and once again it's
flying coach love the name with Steve
Kerr and Pete Carroll and get it on
Spotify in the ringer Steve good to talk
to you thank you yeah all right they saw
Dan